[Musique]
madame messieurs chers amis jeunes
avaient faim depuis la mi mars notre
ville comme notre pays vivent au rythme
du coc finement ce confinement imposées
par l'état pour limiter la propagation
du virus caudines je souhaite tout
d'abord remercié la très grande majorité
des jeunes au fn et des génovéfains qui
ont joué le jeu de ce confinement avec
ses règles drastiques c'est vrai qu'ils
ont changé nos habitudes de vie de façon
à ne pas favoriser la propagation de ce
virus
vous savez sans doute le président de la
république a annoncé un déconfinement
progressive de la france à compter du 11
mai alors toutefois ce confinement
progressive de la france sera soumis à
des autorisations gouvernementales qui
devrait intervenir le 7 mai prochain
bien évidemment beaucoup de questions se
posent beaucoup de questions se posent
et je le sais que vous êtes nombreuses
et nombreux à vous opposer notamment sur
la question de la distribution des
masques
le premier ministre a indiqué que le
port du masque serait souhaitable pour
les français nous n'avons pas attendu du
côté de la ville
cet engagement de l'état pour procéder
nous mêmes à la commande de masques pour
notre population
ainsi nous allons recevoir avant le 11
mai des masques lavables et
réutilisables qui seront distribués à
votre domicile nous partons sur le
principe qu'il y aura la distribution
d'un masque par adulte 1 un masque pour
chaque génovéfains âgés de plus de 11
ans puisque vous le savez sans doute le
haut conseil scientifique ne favorise
pas le port du basque pour les enfants
de moins de 11 ans je sais aussi que
beaucoup de questions se posent sur un
sujet majeur
il s'agit de la réouverture des écoles
vous savez sans doute
le département de l'essonne est classé
en zone rouge c'est à dire que nous
faisons partie des départements où le
virus circule encore trop fortement
alors ce classement nécessitera encore
des mesures assez strict et je pense
notamment à l'accès au parc à la
fermeture des collèges ou à la fermeture
des lycées
toutefois le gouvernement a souhaité que
les écoles que ce soit des écoles
maternelles ou élémentaires puisse
réouvrir alors je le dis clairement nous
avons travaillé avec les services de
l'éducation nationale et je remercie
l'ensemble des enseignantes et des
enseignants de la ville
l'ensemble des professeurs également en
collège et en lycée qui est depuis la mi
mars ont permis à nos jeunes génovéfains
de pouvoir poursuivre leur scolarité au
travers notamment de de ses cours à
distance
nous avons travaillé avec les directions
d'école de la ville avec l'inspectrice
également de l'éducation nationale de la
ville pour voir dans quelle mesure nous
pourrions avancer sur la réouverture des
écoles
cette réouverture des écoles elle est
conditionnée au respect strict d'un
protocole sanitaire qui nous a été
transmis le dimanche 3 mai pour une
réouverture des écoles le 11 mai
prochain
ce protocole sanitaires strictes qui
doit assurer la sécurité sanitaire temps
des élèves que des écoles est
extrêmement contraignant tant pour les
équipes enseignantes que pour les
personnels de
la ville à la lecture de ce protocole
j'ai a proposé aux élus de la ville et
aux directions d'école de ne pas rouvrir
les écoles maternelles à côté du 11 mai
en effet nous estimons que ce protocole
le respect des gestes barrières les la
distanciation sociale pour les élèves de
maternelle est extrêmement difficile
voire quasi impossible à respecter ce
qui doit nous guider
c'est avant tout la sécurité sanitaire
temps des élèves que des personnels qui
sont dans l'école c'est ce qui guide nos
réflexions à chaque instant le fait de
ne pas rouvrir les écoles maternelles
ont semaine permettra de pouvoir
totalement redéployer les personnels
mobilisables et je pense notamment aux
personnels de la ville qui s'occupe de
l'entretien de l'hygiène et qui
s'occuperont de la désinfection des
locaux scolaires sur l'ensemble des
écoles élémentaires sur la base des
préconisations de l'éducation nationale
l'ensemble des élèves ne en âge d'être
scolarisés en élémentaire ne pourront
être accueillis chaque semaine
l'éducation nationale prévoit un retour
à l'école
selon les semaines donc il y aura une
partie des élèves qui pouvoir retourner
à l'école en semaine à et une autre
partie en semaine b
toutefois il est préconisé et les
directives de l'éducation nationale
préconise la constitution de groupes
d'élèves qui
peuvent aller de 10 à 15 élèves pour les
écoles élémentaires
il a été fait le choix par les équipes
de l'éducation nationale de pouvoir
constituer des groupes de dix élèves à
l'échelle par groupes dans chaque école
s'agissant de la restauration scolaire
nous nous appuyons sur les
préconisations du haut conseil
scientifique qui est préconise la
restauration scolaire dans les salles où
se trouveront les groupes de façon à
limiter les brassages entre élèves
c'est sur cette base sur ces
préconisations que nous prévoirons la
restauration scolaire pour les enfants
qui seront scolarisés
nous gardons la même philosophie pour
permettre l'accueil post scolaire
c'est-à-dire après la journée d'école de
façon à permettre aux parents qui
travailler je pense notamment ceux qui
travaillent loin de pouvoir laisser
leurs enfants sur cet accueil post
scolaire il ne s'agira pas d'étude mais
bien d'un accueil avec des activités de
loisirs compatibles bien évidemment avec
le protocole sanitaire qui nous a été
transmis
concernant le l'accueil de loisirs
élémentaire nous partirons sur la même
base pour proposer une solution aux
généraux fn est haut génovéfains pour
l'accueil du mercredi
là encore en limitant et en évitant le
brassage des jeunes génovéfains en
capacité d'être accueillies dans ces
centres de loisirs alors j'ai bien
conscience que cette solution n'est pas
idéale elle nous est imposée par
par le gouvernement dans cet état de
crise sanitaire nous allons travailler
avec les équipes de l'éducation
nationale sur cette première phase
keira non pas du 11 mai pour les écoles
élémentaires mais du 14 mai puisque nous
avons fait le choix avec les directions
d'école de proposer un accueil pour les
enfants d'élèves scolarisés dans nos
écoles élémentaires à partir du 14 mai
ces trois jours nous permettront de
stabiliser avec les équipes de
l'éducation nationale dans les locaux
dans chaque école
les dispositifs sanitaires de façon à
assurer la meilleure sécurité sanitaire
des élèves à compter du 14 mai sur cette
première phase de redéploiement du coup
entre le 11 mai et le 2 juin
nous allons travailler au mieux pour
faire en sorte que la vie reprenne son
cours dans les écoles élémentaires de la
ville
mais il faut avoir quand même en tête
que l'école telle qu'elle va être
proposée poste confinement ne sera pas
celle que l'ensemble des enfants ni
l'ensemble des personnels de l'école ont
reconnus avant le confinement
nous sommes dans une situation de
crise sanitaire nous devons veiller
individuellement et collectivement à ce
que le virus ne se propage pas de
nouveau et je finirai par ma vidéo
aujourd'hui pour vous indiquer que le
service éducation les services
municipaux restent mobilisés pour
répondre à vos questions et puis je
voudrais une nouvelle fois remercier
l'ensemble des personnels soignants
l'ensemble des personnels de nos
collectivités qui sont mobilisés depuis
le début de la crise pour faire en sorte
que l'idée du service public l'idée de
la solidarité
genf fn puisse perdurer et qui soit
vraiment le plus possible au contact de
nos populations je vous remercie de
votre écoute attentive juste vous dire
que j'ai souhaité que vous soit
communiquée dans chacune de vos boîtes
aux lettres
au cours du week-end 1 une lettre qui
expliquera les grands axes du
déconfinement sur la ville de sainte
geneviève des bois bien évidemment avec
l'ensemble dès élus de la ville mais
l'ensemble des agents communaux nous
restons mobilisés à vos côtés dans cette
période des plus difficiles pour toutes
et tous